é pensar uma cidade para pessoas em
princípio a gente pode imaginar que bom
todas as cidades são pessoas porque
afinal é onde as pessoas vivem
mas a gente pode repensar esse conceito
e se essa cidade está sendo efetivamente
para pessoas
eu comecei a pensar mais nesse conceito
a partir de uma experiência avassaladora
essa experiência foi morava numa numa
rua do centro histórico de porto alegre
uma rua calçada com paralelepípedos e
vivíamos ali à nossa vida até que um dia
nossa vida normal até que um dia uma
serpente preta cobriu a rua ela
amanheceu asfaltada primeiro momento a
gente não se deu conta que impacto isso
poderia ter na vida das pessoas mas em
pouco tempo nós notamos que as crianças
que brincavam na rua começaram a se
recolher e isso tinha um motivo óbvio o
aumento da velocidade dos automóveis a
partir do asfalto da chegada do asfalto
a partir disso um vizinho colocou um
cartaz ano a árvore dizendo que
estranhava que tivéssemos recebido
asfalto quando havia tantas demandas
nessa rua que nós não tínhamos nunca
recebido desde lixeiras desde bancos
para as pessoas sentarem de espaços de
convivência no lugar dos espaços de
convivência
nós ganhamos um asfalto que não tinha
sido pedido de lá pra cá eu comecei a
pensar inclusive academicamente porque
também sou professora do que isso uma
cidade na qual nós gostaríamos de viver
em que cidade nós gostaríamos de viver
pra isso me ajudaram algumas obras
alguns livros que eu saiba nenhum deles
ainda está publicado no brasil
um é o siga sua pipa ou do dinamarquês e
até o que é um urbanista e que pensa
especificamente esse conceito de cidade
por pessoas
o outro é um livro muito simpático muito
alegre de um projeto chamado cidade das
crianças de francisco tonut 15 pedagogo
italiano e outros chama na utopia
escrito por chris caução que é um dos
mentores inspiradores das massas
críticas
vou falar um pouquinho de cada um desses
cursos
feitos para reunidos a gente poder
pensar no que seria uma cidade para
pessoas que eu imagino que seja a cidade
que nós todos queremos ver uma maneira
construir podemos construir juntos nós
podemos ter alguns parâmetros
indicadores pra gente pensar se a gente
vive numa cidade para pessoas
nós começamos nos perguntando se a gente
tem uma determinada sensação a sensação
de que cada dia na cidade é melhor do
que foi o dia anterior
a gente faz essa pergunta a nossa cidade
a gente está começando a refletir sobre
o que é uma cidade para pessoas e se nós
estamos inseridos numa cidade para
pessoas a gente pode se perguntar se tem
havido por parte do poder público se ele
for voltado para esse conceito
fechamento de ruas para uso de pedestres
na nossa cidade nos últimos tempos
alguma rua foi fechada para uso
exclusivo de pedestres
a gente pode se pensar se ouve
alargamento de calçadas comecem pensando
na rua de vocês depois só pensando no
bairro nas ruas em geral
alguma delas foi alargada para que as
pessoas possam caminhar lado a lado e
desfrutar mais da rua o que aconteceu
foi o contrário estão ávidos subtrações
de ruas e praças para pistas de
automóveis
nós temos - cidade para pessoas quanto
mais nós tivermos o incentivo à prática
de automóveis individuais
vocês vejam que estou começando
desconstruindo então o conceito para
depois a gente fazer essa idéia da
reconstrução o que é isso incentivo
quando as políticas públicas são
pensadas os projetos são pensados
visando tendo como alvo o automóvel ea
facilitação do automóvel individual e
não do transporte público de qualidade e
das ciclovias nós não temos uma cidade
para pessoas
quando a gente tem uma cidade que pensa
em como aumentar a velocidade
nós não estamos pensando numa cidade
para pessoas quando nós temos o
subtração de espaço de praças e áreas
verdes para a passagem de mais
automóveis num s
pessoas quando no meu bairro quando na
minha rua eu percebo que as casas
antigas vão dando lugar a modernos
prédios e com isso a memória afetiva da
cidade vai se perdendo
mesmo que essas casas não têm um valor
histórico comprovado mesmo que essas
casas não sejam tombadas
mas elas têm a memória afetiva da cidade
elas podem não ser nenhum padrão de
estética mas é ali que eu conheço as
pessoas que moraram famílias que moraram
e o qq relação à estabeleciam com essa
rua quando eu tenho processos de
higienização da cidade que eu vou
afastando determinadas pessoas pessoas
de classe popular empurrando as da
periferia e não estou pensando numa
cidade para pessoas em que as diferentes
classes sociais convivem
mas eu posso pensar eu tenho diante
disso diante da possibilidade de viver a
cidade e outra maneira
duas opções ou a resignação ou a
resistência dessas escolhas
obviamente que a resignação é a pior
porque a resignação é a anti cidadania é
quando eu renuncio a deixar a minha
marca na cidade onde eu vivo em
compensação a resistência é a forma como
nós aqui estão os exemplos pessoas
querem resistir se não vocês não
estariam aqui pensando e como
reconstruir como pensar novos conceitos
para a nossa vida quando a gente se
pretende resistir a gente pode começar a
se espelhando em experiências que
existem outros lugares e depois podemos
criar ou em paralelo às nossas próprias
experiências e várias dessas vem
acontecendo como quando eu tenho o ser
humano como referência eu começo a
pensar desde outro modelo de cidade
o livro que mencionei pra vocês antes do
francisco donuts idade das crianças
é um livro que traz uma perspectiva bem
interessante e uma perspectiva um
projeto que se realizou numa cidade da
itália e se realiza em algumas outras
cidades que parte de uma tese
a tese é a seguinte as cidades essas em
que nós vivemos
elas têm como parâmetro um tipo de
habitantes que é um adulto trabalhador
de idade média que ele é um sujeito
veloz capaz forte todo tipo nos leva a
pensar que uma boa cidade poderia ter
como parâmetro não esse adulto mais uma
criança
se a cidade fosse voltada para a criança
e pensada para o bem estar da criança
essa cidade ficaria boa pra criança
naturalmente mas não só pra ela vai
ficar boa para todos de cabeça boa para
gestante para a pessoa com deficiência
para o idoso
ela ficaria uma cidade de fato
democrática então ele pensa uma série de
projetos em que se ouve à criança e à
criança diz no concelho de crianças como
que deveria ser a cidade que elas
gostariam de viver
o interessante disso é que quando as
crianças criam e projetam uma cidade boa
pra elas
a gente percebe que a cidade ficar boa
para todos
neste caso a mobilidade pública ela se
dá baseada no transporte público de
qualidade é quase um chavão mas é um
chavão que faz tanta diferença numa
cidade a gente sabe que tem segurança
para se transportar e se transforma se
portar de maneira a pontual e com
qualidade
a gente pensa na de novo na ideia das
calçadas largas época calçada larga é um
convite às pessoas desfrutarem um espaço
público retomaria o espaço que é delas
que é o espaço público que a rua a de
tempos em tempos as crianças propõe que
deva haver bolsões que ou roubam uma
pista de rolamento um pedaço da pista de
rolamento que se junta a calçada ou se
junta um terreno baldio
nesses bolsões as crianças podem brincar
mas podem jogar na rua os bancos do
slide não são bancos financeiros são
bancos das pessoas sentarem estão
fazendo uma caminhada elas então elas
descansam as esperam alguém ela só de
lanche antes de prosseguir a sua
caminhada essas cidades voltadas para as
crianças e voltadas para todos nós
elas estabelecem as chamadas zonas 30 às
zonas 10 e que 30
outro número abaixo de 30 corresponde a
velocidade máxima dos automóveis
vocês vejam que nas zonas delas
automóvel usando praticamente na mesma
velocidade de um pedestre acompanhando o
pedestre nessas nessa proposta do tonut
ele cria chamada multa moral a multa
moral é um adesivo que a criança tem na
sua mochila quando ela encontra um carro
estacionado na calçada ela tem o direito
de colar um adesivo bem por dentro do
carro que diz o senhor motorista senhor
é um mal educado por que atrapalhou a
nossa brincadeira a criança assassina é
a multa moral coloca data e ela pode
também preencher o tipo de infração que
foi cometida então essa experiência de
muito muita moral tem criado uma uma
auto vigilância dos motoristas antes
deles colocarem seus carros sobre a
calçada está sendo usada pelas crianças
algumas micro revoluções que acontece em
várias partes do mundo são muito
interessantes para a gente ter como
inspiração necessariamente uma cópia
mais uma inspiração pra pensar como é
que a gente pode rever os conceitos que
a gente tem atualmente cidade de
velocidade e de mobilidade
uma dessas experiências bem
interessantes que acontece na europa e
américa do norte o chamado ônibus a pé
o ônibus a pé é 11 diz o nome né
um ônibus que não é motorizado em que as
pessoas andam a pé principalmente para
levar as crianças para a escola então
são rotas pré-estabelecidas como se
fosse um ônibus normal com paradas onde
a família leva a criança espera a hora
que o ônibus passa o ônibus é um cortejo
de pessoas levados por dois adultos né o
motorista vai na frente um cobrador que
não cobra mas conduz né as crianças eles
têm várias formas de sinalização eles
levam plaquinha de ônibus a pé é um
recado para os motoristas placa pare as
crianças então carregam e mostram para
os motoristas quando elas querem
atravessar e o resultado disso segundo
as escolas onde essas práticas têm sido
implementados extremamente positivo
as crianças no trajeto já realizaram
trocas sociais já conversaram já se
atualizar
eram elas interagem com a cidade porque
elas estão a pé
nós só conhecemos uma cidade quando
andamos a pé nela porque a velocidade do
olho é a velocidade do pé não é a
velocidade do automóvel nem mesmo de
bicicleta a e as crianças chegou então
com físico cansado ea mente oxigenada
então estão prontas para uma aula em que
elas vão ficar um certo tempo sentados
até a hora do recreio
também nesses países existem vários
projetos de educação para o trânsito
realizado nas escolas em que
diferentemente do que a gente vê em
algumas experiências aqui as crianças
não aprendem a ser motoristas elas não
estão num carrinho a que simula um
automóvel para serem depois motoristas
elas andam de bicicleta ou a pé
nesses trajetos que simulam então para
aprender a se realizasse a relacionar
com a rua na condição de pedestre e
ciclista
então deixa pra ser pensar como é seu
motorista na idade apropriada se fizer
essa opção por seu motorista
as massas críticas já não temos mais uma
estatística de quantas cidades têm hã hã
hã implementado esse projeto de massa
crítica
uma parte você deve conhecer mas de
qualquer maneira o encontro de ciclistas
para celebrar a bicicleta que acontece
nas última sexta-feira do mês quando
então a partir de um ponto pré-combinado
ciclistas horizontalmente decidem qual
vai ser o trajeto e celebra a bicicleta
convidam os motoristas a pensar uma
outra forma de modalidade e inverte a
lógica da massa apocalíptica que
acontece todos os dias que é um
engarrafamento de automóveis
então nesse dia as bicicletas é que vão
estar na rua
outras experiências interessantes também
essas micro revoluções da cidadania
retomando o espaço que é seu que o
espaço público é da jardinagem
bicicletada também acontece mediante o
uso da bicicleta então ciclistas que se
encontram no fim da tarde ou no fim
semana elevam mudas de que plantas e de
árvores e flores e percorrem espaço da
cidade implantando né
às vezes passo que a gente não se dá
conta que poderiam ser um canteiro ninho
se torna um lindo canteiro e chama a
atenção das pessoas
uma das nossas experiências de
bicicleta' gem jardinagem bicicletada ou
escutar jade na área ela foi tão
interessante que a gente foi à frente do
edifício começou a plantar os moradores
do edifício venceram o que eles acharam
estranha um terreno grande sem cerca tem
nada
na perimetral de porto alegre eles
estranharam que a gente estava fazendo
primeiro acharam que poderiam estar
destruindo alguma coisa quando se deram
conta que estamos plantando eles ficaram
tão entusiasmados com a gente passou um
mês depois pra ver como é que novas
plantas
eles tinham feito canteiros no próprio
parque e uma senhora dizia estou
envergonhada que pessoas de longe têm
vindo plantar na frente da minha casa
a mostra experiência bem interessante é
a experiência de vaga viva a vaga viva
aqui na foto da renata ip's no bairro
bairro boêmio de porto alegre está de
baixa é a retomada de espaços
estacionamento por pessoas pessoas que
sentam levam tapetes levam poltronas
vasos e ficam conversando no lugar onde
estaria uma lataria né um espaço morto
estão as pessoas fazendo as suas trocas
sociais como no rio grande do sul e
temos nem a roda de chimarrão os
vizinhos começam a se conhecer é é um
vizinho que se encontra no elevador é um
visita sentado na frente do outro na no
espaço público
as pessoas vêm de longe também pra
conhecer a experiência e fazer trocas
então estou chamando de micro revoluções
são ideias pelas quais através das quais
as pessoas retomam aquele espaço que é
seu que o espaço público e assim a tomar
a cidade estão na cidade viva na cidade
para pessoas
o gestor ou administrador ele pensa na
supressão do sal doors né que nos
estimulam ao consumismo ele vai pensar
numa cidade que é boa para as pessoas a
percorrerem e ter experiências
agradáveis a percorrer e caminhando
interagindo com outras pessoas
neste caso por exemplo o tempo do
semáforo não pode ser como normalmente
ele é ele é
apertado para o pedestre ele quando tem
que apertar um botão e aperta o botão
espera uma eternidade geral tenha dado
para atravessar antes de ficar favorável
pra se o sinal teria que ser o contrário
é o pedestre ser a referência à altura
dos edifícios eles o difícil são segundo
esses projetos do edifício da cidade
pessoas não pode ter mais de cinco
andares que são a maneira de a forma
pela qual uma mãe pode chamar uma
criança para brincar se para a refeição
porque está brincando no seu pátio lá
embaixo e uma série de outras propostas
pensadas a de hortas públicas enfim de
maneiras pelas quais as pessoas podem se
apropriar do espaço público numa cidade
para pessoas
a gente vai ter 11 gente cria problemas
para o poder público que nem sempre sabe
resolvê-los e han se dar conta de que o
espaço público é das pessoas quando a
gente resiste a isso a gente não vai ter
não vai repetir experiências como as que
a gente viveu recentemente em porto
alegre e que a foto retrata bem uma foto
do jogo saber rio e acho que a foto fala
por si
mas nós que estamos aqui a gente resiste
não permite que fatos assim se repitam
nessa ou em qualquer outra cidade muito
obrigada
[Aplausos]